chris when you got to la you got lucky
with head shots very early on yeah i
that was yeah that was something that i
knew i needed was head shots everyone
says you need headshots and so i was on
the hunt for headshots but i was
completely broke and uh
i was
i was at the post office in west
hollywood which is uh
an area in l.a that's like a
predominantly gay area
and uh i was there getting hedge getting
uh like picking up some men
what a great story that's a great show
thank you
awesome
well i and i saw this this guy was like
was had this look he was like
like he recognized me i was like
hello
and he was like
you look familiar have i shot you
i was like i've never been shot
i don't believe you've shot me
and he was like no i'm a do you model
i'm a photographer do you model and i
was like no but i need uh have you ever
heard of head shots i need uh something
called headshots i was 20 years old
and the guy's like i do head shots i
live like two blocks from here oh no
i'll give you head shots i was like
well what does it cost he's like
just co it's fine i'll cover you i was
like oh
sweet okay let's go
and so uh
i go to this guy's apartment
he lived on the top floor really nice
apartment amazing furnishings uh
he was like listen
you probably you a little grimey you
probably need a shower i was like that's
a really good
yes i idea yes i did i showered
all kinds of good
soaps and
great i probably needed a shower
and then he was like hmm you should you
should probably wear some different
clothes so he gives me like this nice
nice white shirt that's a polo shirt
nice shirt
and uh and kind of like helps me and
like judges me up and stuff and we go
out on the balcony and and he takes
like a bunch of photos and he's like
directing me telling me what to do
and he takes all these photos and
takes the film out of the camera and he
puts it in the film thing and he just
gives it to me
and he was like
there you go and i just walked out and i
was like yeah that'd stick to that story
as well
[Applause]
look at the picture look at the picture
yeah it's really embarrassing no it's
beautiful
that silenced the audience oh my god
took it in look at my hair that was a
guy who clearly couldn't afford a
haircut let alone a headshot
did you ever see him again i don't know
that i ever saw him again i if you're
watching thank you for my headshots
he's probably making money of those
pictures he took of you in the shower
that you didn't know
[Applause]
you paid him for those yeah but chris
you're someone that seems remarkably
unimpressed by your career
yeah
yeah yeah yeah he really uh couldn't
care less but there's anything like he
doesn't believe you're the real deal
yeah
he i mean
he's now you know fought he'll he'll say
he's five and three quarters and he and
he went to universal uh the other day
universal studios in l.a
theme park had a good time and came back
and he said hey dad guess what today
i saw the real owen
cause like there's this guy at
universal who dresses up like my
character from the movie and
the dinosaurs come out and he's like
does this thing and the kids he's like
i saw the real one daddy
so i was like all right yeah
what is he's putting the work in he's
there every day yeah right yeah it's
true actually yeah all year he's there
actually
also
you obviously you know you you have your
parenting rules and all that but
apparently what is it the parenting
rules change if you go fishing
yes that's right that's right um we have
a
we ha i have a farm uh up in washington
state and on on this farm is a lake and
and it's uh we fish a lot for bass on
this lake my son and i
and i had this rule with my old man and
i have it with my son which is when
you're fishing you can swear you can
just swear when you're fishing it's just
the guys
go ahead and let loose
and so we're out fishing he catches a
fish and i'm trying to get him to take a
picture with the fish before we let it
go and it flops out of his hands and it
and these bass have these little spines
on on their back and the fin pokes them
in the hand falls in the water he starts
to cry
and he's like oh
and i said hey buddy are you all right
you're all right he said oh
dad i'm about to swear
i said hey you know you know the rules
and he goes that bass that bass is
stupid
because well you know i think we say hey
don't say someone call someone stupid
that's bad you shouldn't say that and i
and he continues to cry did you feel
better he said
a little bit stupid stupid bass and i
was like
like uh all right buddy yeah you know
now's the time get it out and he goes he
was that stupid bass is a [__] [__]
[Applause]
i'm like
oh all right
i said before about how you you came to
stand up late and the jobs you did
before you did it and there's a weird
kind of connection between john and
chris because now was it yeah i get my
dick up on girls
but no you you were a hoover salesman
yeah it was okay so as a hoover salesman
you've talked about this
ritual you had to go through yeah yeah i
worked for a car i was 17 something like
that i worked for a company called a kb
cleaners but you'd have to go in in the
morning and sing
sing before you go out to tell try and
sell [__] cleveland to the world yeah
and it was i think it was an american
concept that he brought over and and it
was just bizarre what are you saying
well you know all the sales it was
commission only so you get in this room
and all this and enthusiasm yeah
yeah yeah i mean there was some sheets
they give you some sheets and it'd be
like this is to the tune of i want to
hold you down by the beatles and go i
want to sell a cleaner
i want to sell a clean
i
never do that it's honest to god it was
just like that and you'd go in and sting
and there was always one guy who'd
always try and get into the room first
because he wants us to play the drums
it was mad because as a 17 year old of a
suit that barrels from a friend i
thought that's what all jobs were like
here's the weird thing chris pratt could
have been your boss because you sort of
did this what was it coupons you were
saying yeah it was coupons yeah i did i
had the same thing i was like a
multi-level marketing salesman job and
we did a chant in the morning just to
clarify what's a coupon a coupon is like
a it's like a certificate it's a for a
promotion so we would sell
coupons for businesses in the service
industry like a day spa type thing a
salon to like come and you know get all
uh dolled up and and like get your hair
done and your nails done give them the
gifts right you can give them a gift you
can give them as gifts yeah but you're
giving i look for opportunities that's
what you're giving i was not i was i was
i was
yeah i was it was one of those things
where if you work very hard and you stay
enthusiastic and you follow the steps
and you do the chant in the morning i
mean i was i was hook line and sinker uh
you know you can open your own office
and like start your own business and i
did i like made it all the way to the
top i opened my own office at 19 i had
my own business and um
and went to a state in
colorado and i opened my own office in
denver and put an ad in the paper the
same ad that i had answered which said
you like rock and roll music you want to
make money
test
i'm only interested in hiring
like an idiot
did you answer that ad check that box
yes i do like money that's crazy and i
also like rock and roll music uh quick
you haven't already filled the position
have you
yes we put that same ad in the paper and
it turned out like it it wasn't all
enthusiastic 18 year olds like myself
who answered it was like the bottom of
the unemployment bank
just terrible
people who would i'd send out to sell
and represent my company and they would
like rob a place
it was just terrible
your chance made no sense not at all
every morning
tell me how you're feeling and we'd go
fantastic terrific great oh yeah strong
juice baby sucker i feel wonderful right
on right on right on juice juice
[Music]
i feel great i feel great
let's kick some ass kick some ass who's
number one we are who's number two who
gives a phone
[Applause]
it is traditional at this point in the
show when john bishop is on the couch to
turn to the americans to say
understanding anything yeah
no no i'm getting it all right
oh yeah yeah good good he said he was in
the fellowship of the ring
[Laughter]
because talking talking of accents this
is a weird thing so chris pratt is this
seems so unlikely that you have now
learned how to do the voices from towie
yeah sort of yeah
we love that garbage tv back in
in the states
my wife was crazy about it and when i
was
here filming guardians we shot guardians
of the galaxy here in in london and
and my wife anna came out to visit
and she fell in love with this show
towie the only way is essex it's this
show that's like basically their jersey
shorts the jersey shore from right from
here it's like this uh
town somewhere essex i guess and
these folks are just like the worst and
it was like i'm a parrot a little bit
and so when i hear when i hear it all
the time i just started picking it up
and started like i could pick up their
accent and do their accent a little bit
you know yeah i'm okay it's gonna sound
this is really embarrassing to do in
front of a whole room full of brits here
but i'll try it anyways so it's like
so like honestly i like i saw this guy
honestly
like michael cheated on me when he was
in a beef heart and i was like
because he's telling me he's like you
know no i miss you or whatever and i'm
like
you miss me what am i your mother
[Applause]
that will never be useful that would be
useful but that's very good now i want
to watch the show
i love the fact that you spent months in
english and that's what you talk about
i had no idea but chris pratt i hear i
hear you are a magician
dude yes i am respect
yeah well i have a position magician
like uh like i know real magic yes no
these are not
like the secrets yeah
well i i've i
know some tricks it's been a while
because these now i honestly these cards
chris didn't bring these cards they just
we got them yeah if i give you these
cards
can you do magic
real magic magic yes yeah not a trick
you have to be very careful about
practicing in the dark arts
lots of flourishes
um okay
okay here we go now it's been a while so
if i screw this up
just you know you'll cut it out
um yeah this is a whole new deck
i haven't seen this deck
you haven't shown me this deck you know
uh th this is
a deck
of cards
captivated yet
so i'm gonna shuffle it
i also played a magician in the movie
the magnificent seven i saw that thank
you
you like movies
and uh and so i learned i got to
practice a little bit there okay i need
um
[Music]
a volunteer should i
all right i got will i am this is
awesome i'm doing a card trick for will
i am i love my life
um okay so here's what we're gonna do
this is called burnham and it works
fifty percent of the time
so
i'm going to make three piles should i
just
now will i am may i call you will i am
yeah is that okay hell yeah um take this
card
and pick it up and put it on actually
you know put it on either side of these
piles you want face up this card right
here
oh take that card take that card and put
it face up on either side oh yeah i get
it yeah yeah yeah and now take that card
and put it put it there face up
hell yeah now
this
is your card but do not let me see it
but show uh everybody okay that's your
card don't let me see it okay i'll come
with this and don't say anything oh good
card and when you're and when you're
finished
committing to get to memory put it back
in the middle pile anywhere anywhere
inside
put it anywhere you want in the middle
pile
hide it and make it so that i could
never know where you put it
okay
you got it yeah boom on that show
now
whoo two fours
i call this trick
two fours
i take one four
on the bottom one four on top now what
do i know i know that your card you
remember your card don't tell me what's
that it's somewhere inside
this little deck but i don't know where
it is
so i'm gonna put that in the middle what
and put that right there now i want you
to shuffle that
four times
now i like i told you this only works
half the time so if it doesn't work i'm
going to be really embarrassed
one shuffle
two shuffles
three shuffles
[Applause]
but that's okay let's try
now what all great magicians say
one two yes four okay now i'm gonna look
because i'm gonna find your car don't
don't don't look at my process wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait how
many chances you get to find the car
though because we can sit there for
hours i guess four oh you get four
chances yep okay that seems fair 30
minutes each yeah this is a different
segment of the graham norton show
okay let's see here no no that's not it
oh it's coming
it's gonna be here okay hold on i think
i got it
nope
okay hold on
i have four chances wait a second will
you count
four chances to shuffle through them or
four chances to show him a year he just
no he's just looking he's looking for
your card i'm looking for your card okay
i got it
come on come on
the first chance
dear lord god please
it's called
burnham i take one i burn it i might
have burned your card
will i am your card hell no oh okay hold
on
uh is this your card
hell no just tell me your card now
because this could be it
what is your card
you can tell me now because i wouldn't
be able to take it out tell me it's an a
an a of hearts a of hearts
yeah
the ace of hearts
no no
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait i'm not done i'm not done hey
rhyme though
your card
eight eight is in this pile
i'll shazam
no hell no
will i shazam oh no no no
that's good i think it was your card
give me a fist bump wait a second magic
fist bump
keep it right there
don't move it
squeeze
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
you